tense moment in the Skies over kieve
last night a drone spotted overhead in a
capital bracing for Russian retaliation
a stinger missile shoots it out of the
sky
to the cheers of Glory to Ukraine
Ukrainian defense officials later said
it was one of their own which had gone
Rogue
a city that's been targeted by Russian
drones and missiles several nights this
week residents are understandably
jittery
especially after the attempted drone
strike at the Kremlin whoever was behind
it U.S officials tell CBS news they
believe the drones were locally
controlled but that doesn't rule out
Ukrainian involvement